Ми познайомилися з Максимом у східнонімецькому Вайсенфельсі.
Своє справжнє ім'я наш співрозмовник не розголошує,
побоюючись накликати на себе гнів фірми-посередника,
яка відправила його на заробітки до Німеччини.
Відправила з підробленими документами.
Перебуваючи в Україні, мені захотілося заробити побільше.
Як, у принципі, всі українці хочуть цього.
Я звернувся до фірми в Україні з працевлаштування.
З легального, як там говорили, працевлаштування,
і подав документи. Потім мені прийшов такий документ, за яким
я вже міг виїжджати в Німеччину, працювати в місто Вайсенфельс,
на мясокомбінаті, за 9,35 € за годину.
Умови роботи хлопця цілком влаштовували.
З самого початку, як ми їхали сюди, ми мали працювати на упаковці,
Одяг у нас спеціальний був.
На самій фірмі видали такі туфлі з залізною набійкою спереду, на носку,
щоб якщо щось впаде, не пошкодити ногу. Також була
футболка, і на самому заводі вже можеш хоч кожного дня
брати собі халат і штани. Шапочки, маски, рукавиці - все видають.
Ну і стерильно, в принципі, все.
Максим вийшов на роботу, але встиг попрацювати лише 5 днів.
До нього і його товаришів прийшла з обшуками поліція. Як до нелегалів.
Того дня мене вдома не було, я був на роботі. Як вийшло,
в останній свій робочий день. Коли я прийшов додому, в мене був
зламаний замок і замінений на новий. І висів папірець такий,
де було написано перекладачем, що в нашій квартирі була поліція,
яка провела обшук, яка зламала нам замок, замінила його.
Під облаву потрапили того дня наприкінці вересня більше 80
заробітчан - українців, грузинів, поляків.
Їх звинувачують у незаконному в'їзді та перебуванні в Німеччині,
адже працювали вони тут під виглядом "студентів". Довідки
про навчання були "липові", сфабриковані буцімто
одним з українських вишів.
Серед них були й реальні студенти, які мають статус студентів в Україні.
У принципі, якби вони законно оформили свої довідки
про навчання, то могли б абсолютно легально тут працювати.  Проте,
вочевидь, підозрюваним фірмам не захотілося навіть ускладнювати себе
оформленням цим студентам справжніх паперів.
Ось довідка Максима про право на студентську роботу,
яку дала йому фірма-посередник. На бланку та з печаткою
Федерального агентства з працевлаштування Німеччини.
У цьому агентстві на прохання DW перевірити справжність документу
послалися на таємницю слідства та особистих даних. Але підтвердили,
що їхні дозволи виглядають саме так.
Офіс рекрутингової компанії International Work у центрі Києва -
однієї з багатьох, які надають такі послуги в Україні.
За словами Максима, саме вона знайшла йому начебто
студентську роботу. На своїй сторінці у Фейсбуку фірма
продовжує далі публікувати аналогічні оголошення
про працевлаштування за кордоном. Десятки оголошень щодня і фото
дозволів на роботу, буцімто отриманих у німецькому
агентстві праці.
Тим часом на запит DW компанія відповіла, що не може
прокоментувати події зі "студентами", а також заявила, що не має жодних
відносин із Федеральним агентством працевлаштування ФРН.
Коли я задав питання таке, що я не студент, як ми будемо
робити ці документи не студентські? Вони сказали: ти не переживай,
це вже не твоя компетенція.
Максим стверджує, що за своє посередництво фірма взяла з нього
500 євро. Це суперечить законам Німеччини. Студенти можуть
влаштовуватися на роботу під час канікул через державне агентство
працевлаштування ФРН, і посередництво суворо заборонене.
DW вдалося поспілкуватися у Вайсенфельсі з іншими
фігурантами "студентської афери". Як вони стверджують,
реальними студентами.
Ми за цією програмою, у принципі, і їхали. Але вийшло так,
що ми стали жертвами як з боку Україи, так і з боку Німеччини,
тому що в Україні ми витратили багато грошей.
У нашому випадку це тисяча євро.
А в Німеччині нам просто не виплатили зарплату.
У нас немає грошей навіть на квиток додому. Ані фірма "Беркана",
ані фірма "Тьонніс" не йдуть з нами на жодний контакт.
Не хочуть нічого виплачувати, не хочуть нічого компенсувати.
Їх видворили з Німеччини. Усім тепер - заборона в'їзду
до Шенгенської зони на 3 роки. Інвестиції - а це близько 1000 євро
на комісійні, дорогу та проживання - переросли у борги.
У німецькій прокуратурі кажуть, що з українцями-порушниками
обійшлися ще відносно м'яко.
Ідеться про порівняно м'яке обвинувачення - незаконний в'їзд
та незаконне перебування в Німеччині. Це не злочин,
а правопорушення, і якщо вони не мали досі проблем із законом, то
справу щодо них ми, найімовірніше, закриємо.
Ці потерпілі, зрештою, частково й самі стали жертвами шахрайства,
тому що їх пообіцяли влаштувати начебто на легальну роботу,
і ми, звичайно, зважимо на це і закриємо справу.
Основне ж розслідування ведеться проти фірми "Беркана", зареєстрованої
в Німеччині, яка запрошувала українців
за "студентською програмою". У неї конфіскували
півтора мільйона євро грошима та майном. Це сума, яку, за оцінками,
заробили шахраї.  Фігурантам загрожує від 1 року позбавлення
волі за кожен зі злочинних епізодів.
У тому числі й одній громадянці України.
Це м'ясокомбінат "Тьонніс", один з найбільших у Німеччині.
Фактично це колишній роботодавець Максима, але формально він тут
не працював. Його надавала "у користування"
за угодою лізингу фірма "Беркана".
Шанси повернути зароблене тепер - мізерні. До речі, студенти
розповідають, що до Німеччини їхали на зовсім іншу роботу.
Були три вакансії, з яких можна було вибирати - це
"робота в супермаркеті", "кондитерська", "хлібобулочна" -
ось ці три вакансії. А ми попали на зовсім іншу. Це був м'ясокомбінат.
Робота дуже важка - як для дівчат, так і для хлопців.
Дівчата піднімали важкі коробки з м'ясом, м'ясною продукцією,
які важили 25-30 кг. Для чоловіків теж дуже важка робота
і постійно дуже швидкий ритм роботи.
Левову частку з 2200 працівників цієї м'ясофабрики-велетня
винаймають на умовах лізингу. Підприємства-виробники
не обтяжують себе соціальними та правовими гарантіями. Відповідно
важко захищати інтереси таких працівників.
Але уряд Німеччини вже обіцяє заборонити субпідряди.
Ми сподіваємося, що закон про захист праці у м'ясній галузі буде
ухвалено. Міністр праці та уряд ФРН обіцяли ліквідувати
субпідрядників та лізинг у м'ясній галузі, ці паралельні структури, і тоді
ситуація стане прозорішою також і для контролюючих органів,
тож ми хочемо, аби підприємства - фактичні роботодавці - брали на себе
відповідальність за своїх працівників.
Тоді, можливо, підставні фірми не зможуть експлуатувати українців
так, як це сталося в афері з фальшивими студентами.